this is the function that's provided
they say that the domain of this
function is all real values of X is that
correct and then the question is what's
the value of K okay so I just want you
to guys to look at this for a minute and
think through it with me you've got a
function I know normally you might think
of all there's a square root there's a
square root so therefore that means that
I've only got positive values right only
got positive values that's true if you
are thinking about the range if you're
thinking about the range the square root
of anything is defined as the positive
value if you want the negative square
root then you've got a slap a negative
sign behind it okay so the range of this
thing is f of X has to be greater than
or equal to zero but that is a question
about range not about domain okay
domain is about what values of X can I
put in there okay
now quite clearly oh that's embarrassing
man come on yeah this could you know
yeah that's fine
quite clearly there are functions
involving a square root like that guy
where you can put in any value of x that
you like on the square root of x squared
that's actually something else you've
heard of before what is that that's the
absolute value of X right and aren't
that exists for all values of X the
domain is is the same okay so what does
it mean for this the reason why this
exists for all real values of X is
because no matter what you put into X
you always end up with a positive or
zero underneath the square root
do you agree with that you can put
negative numbers in there positive
numbers you're fine okay but if I change
this around a little bit use this space
over here let's try something like this
okay what is the domain of this I need
to make sure that everything underneath
the square root is greater than or equal
to zero
so this if I solve this that will give
me the domain of this function here as
it happens let's say that's x squared
once so roughly it looks like this so
that's one that's negative one okay so
which points am i interested in X is
less than or equal to negative one is
okay that's all right that's above or X
is greater than or equal to positive one
that's also okay right so in a case like
this you can see the domain isn't
everything it's only some things okay
let me give you one more example square
root of x squared plus one plus one
instead of minus one what's the domain
now the domain of this one is all real X
just like this one because think about
it think about what's underneath the
square root
think about x squared plus one when is
this graph greater than or equal to zero
and if you think I deliberately chose
this because it's an easy graph when you
think about the graph it's always
greater than or equal to zero every
value of x they're all fine these guys
are all fine okay
now convert that over to what this
question is about we're trying to work
out hey when is this thing always above
always above the x-axis always positive
bit awkward keeping on saying like
always this always that if only I had
some kind of language that the described
a quadratic function like this that was
definitely positive no wonder what no
matter what kind of value I put in or
wait we do have losers for that we're
looking for this the reason why this
works all the time as opposed to this
guy is that this one is indefinite yeah
some guys are positive some days are
negative whereas this one is what's it
called again it's definite it's not just
definite it's it's positive definite
okay it's important that you say it's
positive definite because if you have a
negative definite function for example
something like this see this guy what's
this guy it's that function right what's
the domain of this function
there is there's not a single value of x
you can put in there it never works
right you put any x value in there you
always get something negative underneath
the square root so this this guy's not a
very interesting thing to draw so what
I'm trying to do now therefore is if I
want positive definite I know it works
for this now I'm trying to think about
it for this guy let's think about the
positive part of positive definite what
is it that makes this positive and not
this one which value is at the total
value
it's the a it's the coefficient of x
squared right that's who I for this guy
it's definite
it's its definite but it's negative
definite that's not good so what's the a
in this case a equals for certain a is
positive that's the first step if a
wasn't positive then forget about it I
don't even need to worry about its
positive definite stuff now I need to
deal with the definite part what's the
condition that a quadratic has to have
for it to be definite I want the
discriminant to be negative because I
don't want any roots if the discriminant
is greater or equal greater than or
equal to zero I'll get a root but I
don't want that okay so now you can do
this now it's actually quite
straightforward to solve you can work
out your B squared minus 4a see that
looks like 4 times 36 which is a hundred
and forty-four how's that looking said
okay so K minus 12 K plus 12 because
it's just difference of squares so you
tell me which values work when is this
think about what it looks like think
about what it looks like when is it
negative very good because this function
here this graph of K has negative 12 12
and these are the good parts these are
the ones I'm interested in
so therefore negative 12 to 12 happy the
hardest part of it really is actually
working out like it's not hard to work
out the discriminant it's knowing that
you should work out the discriminant and
that you want it to be negative make
sense
if I want this situation here right
we're yeah cool the parabola is always
above the way to know that a parabola is
always above is that there are no roots
if there are roots I'm stuffed I've got
this indefinite situation right but I've
been told that this thing doesn't have
roots I've been told that this thing is
always positive so that's why I want to
discriminate negative that'll give me
nerve roots okay